bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
saint-quentin-en-yvelines terre
d'innovation des innovations qui
s'inscrivent également au coeur des
laboratoires de l'université du
territoire et ce dans divers domaines et
une université qui collaborent avec les
entreprises de l'agglomération
je vous propose de faire le tour des
découvertes essentielles de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
classé parmi les meilleures universités
mondiales au classement de shanghai
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines brill dans bien des domaines
plusieurs centaines de chercheurs
collaborent dans ses 35 laboratoires et
une dizaine de plateformes de
technologie de pointe permettent de
mutualiser les moyens chaque année
naissent ainsi de multiples innovations
valorisé par les entreprises du
territoire à l'heure actuelle une
quinzaine de start up sont un cube et au
sein même de l'ue véhicule tous les
espoirs sont permis et les moyens sont
mis pour aider ces start-up pour les
aider dans leur développement les
accompagner est également sollicité nos
partenaires territoriaux la communauté
donc de saint quentin en yvelines
versailles etc pour accompagner ces
start up sur des innovations dont on
espère qu'elles seront à un moment donné
porteuse et
possiblement avec une dimension
internationale
au mondial une université c'est un
symbole fort mais bien sûr l'avenir
c'est de marier les laboratoires publics
privés les universités et les grandes
écoles et les entreprises
l'agglomération de cinq ans d'un soutien
très activement cette université je
crois qu'on a plus de 1000 doctorants on
a déjà
une quinzaine de start up qui sortent
des laboratoires de saint quentin on a
un incubateur qui est prêt aussi qu'ils
aient fait aussi pour ces étudiants qui
veulent passer ensuite à l'étape
entrepreneuriale santé et handicap
économie ou encore le domaine de
l'espace les innovations issues de ces
laboratoires consacrent tous les
domaines d innovation soutenue par
l'autre universités de la région paris
saclay dans le cadre de la commue paris
saclay il y à un certain nombre de
dispositifs extrêmement important alors
des dispositifs de soutien à la
recherche d ce qu'on appelle les
dispositifs structurant de la recherche
mais également pour des soutien à
l'innovation la sat paris-saclay société
accélératrice de transfert technologique
outre le soutien financier apporte aussi
son savoir faire dans le cadre de la
valorisation des brevets grâce à son
expertise juridique et scientifique
autre collaboration celle avec les
entreprises du territoire alors il ya
des liens qui sont directs d'abord en
des laboratoires avec les entreprises
puisque les entreprises pour venir
trouver les laboratoires ou inversement
pour envisager des travaux de recherche
commune ou confier des recherches
particulières qui ont une destination
applicative
hymne aux en est la parfaite
illustration
créé par deux professeurs de
mathématiques de l'université de
versailles saint quentin il vous propose
son expertise et ses outils de calcul
pour aider les entreprises dans leurs
activités
[Musique]
et éventuellement vérifiée c'est qu'une
seule solution
qui est moins 45 données
vérifiées sur ce jour là ses cours de
mathématiques à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour les futurs collaborateurs des
entreprises du territoire ou d'ailleurs
les mathématiques sont présentes partout
dans l'économie sans forcément qu'on
s'en rende compte chaque jour on utilise
des algorithmes mathématiques entre ont
valu de son téléphone on fait de
recherche sur internet on parle environ
10% de l'économie qui est lié à
l'utilisation et usages des
mathématiques le numérique a permis
d'ouvrir de nouveaux horizons aux
entreprises mais elles sont parfois
démunis face aux outils nécessaires à
leur utilisation
hymne aux qui répondent déjà aux
demandes des grandes entreprises de
territoires comme renault peugeot airbus
ou encore thalès souhaite désormais
aider les pme et les tpe dans leurs
problématiques elles ont pas les mêmes
besoins et les mêmes objectifs en termes
de délai dont elles ont besoin de
réponses courtes elles ont des problèmes
mathématiques différents donc nous avons
créé cet institut pour essayer de leur
répondre plus efficacement traitement de
données simulation ou modélisation les
réponses grâce à l'institut moz sont
plus rapides
l'entreprise self eden n'a pas hésité à
faire appel à l'institut afin d'évaluer
la qualité de l'eau dans le cadre de son
activité dacquois pony actuellement des
capteurs coûteux analyse l'eau demain
ces capteurs seront remplacés par une
simulation numérique la compagnie ça
consiste à faire pousser des plantes
des déjections qui comporte
principalement de l'ammoniac
celui ci est transformé en nitrites qui
sera à son tour transformé en nitrates
grâce à diverses bactéries des nitrates
qui seront absorbées par les plantes
donc c'est un cercle vertueux car les
poissons permet de nourrir les plantes
et les plantes permet de filtrer l'eau
des poissons le cycle de nitrification
des données bientôt analyses et paris
moz qui vérifiera la qualité de l'eau
dans laquelle évolueront les poissons
s'ils
n'avaient pas eu la mode on n'aurait pas
pu demander à lui as tu de travailler
pour nous demain le traitement de ces
données par les mathématiques pourrait
offrir de nouveaux débouchés aux
entreprises aux données les veaux
l'entreprise dans tous les domaines qui
ont souvent accumulé des données à
partir de mesures qui les utilisent une
certaine manière mais qui ne se doutent
pas forcément pour pourrez grâce à ces
données se servir de ces données pour
avoir d'autres d'autres marchés
l'institut lui à le savoir faire et les
outils pour faire parler ces données
avec l'avènement du numérique
le recours aux mathématiques est plus
que jamais essentielle
entre mieux autre projet en cinq ans
l'observatoire de
versailles-saint-quentin exempt trahi
ce que n'est pas à sa première
innovation fila et la sonde rosetta ou
encore la mission exomars ces projets
ont tous y était porté au sein de
l'université désormais d'autres travaux
sont à l'oeuvre explications avec un
expert
dans la le spatial de l'observatoire de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines les équipes présentes simule
l'environnement de l'espace la cuve à
vide thermique permet de recréer
l'environnement de l'espace pour les
satellites le vide le chaud et le froid
en fonction de leur position autour de
la terre
ici la start-up exo traille a été créé
l'été dernier pour commercialiser le
projet en cours réaliser le plus petits
propulseurs électriques pour satellites
une des caractéristiques du spatial
actuellement c'est quand
on passe d'une
d'une époque où on faisait des très gros
satellites très cher ou très volumineux
avec des temps de développement très
long très performant également et on
passe aujourd'hui sur
des satellites plus petits qui vont être
moins performant mais on va pouvoir en
mettre plus ce qu'on appelle des
constellations de satellites et donc ces
petits satellites aujourd'hui un défaut
c'est qu'en fait ils ont été miniaturisé
mais leur moteur n'a pas suivi en fait
cette miniaturisation dans la lignée du
projet one web entre airbus et une
entreprise américaine qui vise au
déploiement de 650 satellite la
miniaturisation est à l'oeuvre ici plus
de satellites au dessus de nos têtes
c'est plus de possibilité d'observer la
terre et notamment les évolutions
climatiques mais aussi de développer les
télécommunications et l'internet partout
dans le monde
mélo vs qu travail sur bien d'autres
projets on est d'abord donc une
plateforme de services donc
effectivement on accueille beaucoup d'
équipe scientifique et technique et donc
les projets peuvent être extrêmement
variés donc on a atypique mans sur ce
moyen l'attesté cette année des morceaux
d'instruments qu'ils vont être lancés
sur un satellite d'observation de
l'atmosphère mater on it s ou on n'y a
testé galles des morceaux d'équipements
qui vont atterrir sur mars d'ici
quelques années
transmettre des données par la lumière
ou encore offrir une autre forme de
mobilité c'est le pari de deux start up
ne vivait excuse pour des conneries géré
liste nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
à vélines et
un sujet de thèse de doctorat qui
aboutit à la création d'un prototype
jusqu'à la création d'une start-up
géraud lift
c'est le parcours de lambert traîneau
race soutenue dans son projet par
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines celui ci a créé un dispositif
de locomotion qui combine la technologie
robotique et une fonction de
verticalisation qui se commande à l'aide
d'un smartphone géo livre à l'origine
donc c'est un un projet innovant de
mobilité pour
des personnes à mobilité réduite et puis
au sens large pour tous types d'usagés
c'est un module robotique qui qui vient
se bloquer sur n'importe quel gyropode
si on importe quelle base et qui vient
d'adapter en solutions de mobilité qui
permet à son utilisateur de se déplacer
au cimetière assis que debout une
verticalisation qui offre des avantages
physiologique pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite comme la réduction des
escarres la consolidation des eaux une
meilleure circulation sanguine sans
parler du fait de demeurer à la même
hauteur que les autres une égalité
sociale et psychologique non négligeable
mais pas seulement le gyropode comporte
d'autres avantages encore nos avantages
en termes d'accessibilité d'autonomie
avoir accès à des objets en hauteur à
voir que c'est les emplois
et puis après on a les avantages aussi
du gyropode que nous offre pas un
fauteuil roulant classique c'est le
franchissement c'est l'axé là où tout
terrain version citadine tout terrain le
gyropode de la start-up offrira bientôt
une version un submersible pour les plus
téméraires une innovation qui suscite
déjà l'engouement d'éventuels
utilisateurs jusqu'en argentine ou en
nouvelle zélande des distributeurs outre
atlantique propose aussi de
commercialiser le gyropode en janvier
prochain giro lift sera présent aux crs
de las vegas le plus grand salon mondial
qui présente chaque année les dernières
technologies
quelques étages plus haut les locaux de
howlett comme se connecter à internet
grâce à la lumière rien de saugrenu oled
comme l'a fait votre mobile vous pouvez
vous connecter à internet avec un modem
bidirectionnelle donc dans les deux sens
ça fonctionne dans les deux sens c'est
la lumière visible qui transmet le
signal internet 2 du lampadaire vert
vers l'ordinateur à travers un petit
chat clé usb qu'on n'a pas la longueur
d'une connectivité où les ondes ou
disparus mais où la sécurité est accrue
c'est à dire que le signal de traversant
pas les murs comme le oui si ça lui
confère niveau de sécurité
exceptionnelles bientôt aux lettres
comme entrera dans une nouvelle phase
celle de l'industrialisation des
applications sont d'ores et déjà
proposées dans les secteurs hospitaliers
et des transports on est aujourd'hui un
pionnier mondial de la technologie à une
vingtaine de brevets qui ont été
déposées il est temps à présent d'en
faire des produits commercialisables
industrialisable afin de de créer un
business pérenne pour la société tout
comme giraud lift oled com sera présent
du 9 au 12 janvier 2018 au salon de las
vegas afin d'y présenter son innovation
déjà récompensé de deux prix
internationaux
[Musique]
vous savez tous désormais sur les
innovations réalisées au coeur du
territoire à très bientôt pour de
nouvelles inventions saint-quentinoise
ciao
[Musique]